The function in the last video
is used to report the mean and
the standard error.
Suppose I wanted to also
report a 95% confidence
interval for the mean?
Here I'll construct a
confidence interval.
The qt function is used to
identify the 97.5 quantile of
the T-distribution with n minus
1 degrees of freedom.
There might be some temptation
to concatenate the confidence
interval with the current
results being reported from
the function.
In some instances, this might
be fine, but it isn't a very
clear way to organize
the results.
For example, what if another
user mistakenly thought the
first two values were the
confidence interval and the
last two were the mean and
the standard error?
That could be disastrous.
When multiple objects are
being returned from a
function, it's usually helpful
to return them in a list.
But even now, things might still
be a little bit unclear.
For this reason, it's useful to
add names to each element
of the list.
And before I forget,
I should update
the name of the function.
I'm going to name it GetCI for
Get Confidence Interval.
There's one more change I want
to make before moving on--
making the function slightly
more general by allowing for a
different confidence level.
I'm going to do this using the
second argument called level.
Since the 95% confidence level
is so commonly used, I'll
specify a 0.95 confidence
level as the default.
Next, I need to make some slight
adjustments to the body
of the function to make use
of this new argument.
I can compute the upper
percentile for the confidence
interval, then provide this
as a substitute for 0.975.
Now I can run the function
without specifying a level to
get a standard 95%
confidence level.
Or if I want a different
confidence level, say, 99%, I
can easily make that request.
Suppose the user input a value
for a level of 99 rather than
0.99 for the level argument.
In this application, it would be
nice if the function failed
elegantly and communicated why
there was an error rather than
simply reporting warning.
This will be the top
of the next video.